the courts will decide the outcome for
today and but what I would say is that
Steve Barkley may get a legal win today
but what he has done is he has lost the
public and he has certainly lost nursing
so he has a short-term gain but long
term there's no trust whatsoever from
any of our nursing staff who are in this
government and certainly the public if
you look at what the public are saying
we are the most trusted profession and
we're being dragged through the courts
by the least trusted group of people in
England now what does that say about
this country and about the people that's
leading it the people of this country
know better and they deserve better and
they certainly didn't think that the
clubs of this government would turn to
slaps and slaps in the court house very
quickly this is no way to treat our
nursing staff the people you see
standing here today and any other
country throughout the world would say
the way to do this is through
conciliation and negotiation not
dragging your nurses through the
courtroom